[Music]
hey it's scottie meyer from little light
studios and uh today on i've got a
question um
here's the question my house is divided
what can i do to unify my family on not
watching harmful media
this is actually a question that comes
up more often than not so i'll share a
little personal experience that happened
to me in the very beginning of my
marriage
i was a big fan of of movies and i
really didn't um pay attention to the
ratings i kind of watched no matter what
and when god really convicted me on this
message um i was very quick to respond
to that and my wife she grew up in a
household where the tv was always on
it was background noise in her house as
as she was growing up
and
so
where i kind of understood the message
really quickly and just you know said
okay i need to be very careful of what i
watch my wife wasn't that way
and it was a point of contention between
us um often that was how we spent time
together
and so as i really kind of labored that
with god and i said you know god you you
gave me this woman uh
you you know i can't change her you need
to help change her and i think god
really softened my approach and i and i
kind of changed how i approached this
situation with my wife um i started just
suggesting
um other activities let's play a board
game let's go for a walk let's go for a
bike ride and so i kind of removed her
from that typical time that we would
normally sit down and watch things and
and then as as i would kind of engage
with her i would share with her little
bits of things that i was learning and i
would ask questions and and say hey you
know i really came across this study on
this uh what do you think of this
um and it's kind of the same approach as
if you're going to go witness with
somebody right you want to kind of find
that common ground and then you want to
kind of phrase those questions of here
this is a piece of information i found
what do you think of this
and so um you know maybe a good place to
start would be um finding well uh what
does your family member think is good
content and why
and if you guys can start to begin to
agree with what makes something a
positive thing to watch maybe then you
can soften the approach of getting into
the conversation of well do you think
that if there's good things to watch is
there potentially bad things to watch
um
and that that that way it's not so
threatening um you know just kind of
coming in and and sort of coming in guns
blazing that uh you know you shouldn't
be watching that maybe is is uh
not the best approach so in my case it
worked and actually now today my wife is
even much more cautious of what she
watches and little by little i watched
the tv actually her tv habits change and
the things that we would watch change in
our house and it wasn't just immediately
overnight um and so um i know god was
really working with her in that way so
be able to give your mate that that
space but also try to really suggest and
find alternate things to do that don't
just center around media of course when
you have children in the in the picture
um this question is going to come up a
lot and uh you know as you're raising
your kids you want to raise them to be
able to make good choices with their
media as well so um
it definitely is a important um um
question and if you haven't sat down and
had that conversation with your family i
would highly encourage it i want to
share a bible verse with you
it comes from proverbs 24 3 and 4. by
wisdom a house is built and through
understanding it is established through
knowledge it is its rooms are filled
with rare and beautiful treasures
you know a house isn't built just
immediately overnight and sometimes it
takes time um as a family you really
want to move together as a family unit
and um
and so you know to have a discussion on
these type of topics is a good thing and
you know when the house is divided um
maybe it gives you an opportunity to
then come together and find some common
ground or some way to to do it so it can
it can kind of be spun into a positive
thing and we hope that uh i hope that
this is beneficial to you and thanks for
watching
thanks for sending in your question if
you guys have any more questions we'd
love to hear from you so definitely
write it in the comments or
send it to us
and if you know anybody who would
benefit from this question being
answered go ahead and send them this
video
thanks for watching
[Music]
you